well one person with a strong view on
the strength of the Conservatives in
southwest London and Beyond is the
former education secretary and MP for
Putney just in greeting and welcome
thanks for being on the show thank you
and I just wanted to pick up on some of
people were saying when I went to ones
with because the Conservatives it feels
as though some people feel that they did
better than expected in the local
elections but you still ended up losing
seats and that first gentleman that I
spoke to who said that he likes once was
council he voted conservative locally
but he's going to see what happens on
brexit he's not sure about the
Conservatives nationally I mean you do
have some problems don't you
I think his his comments showed how
pragmatic voters are they really do see
through a lot of the the spin to
something that's much more practical
about what will voting mean for me
in his case he knows he's got a good
local council that's got low council tax
but very good services and that was a
package people want to stay at stay
voting for but actually quite rightly he
sees that as different from who you
might want to support at the next
election indeed I spoke to a Labour
voter he was in a similar position where
he said I've always voted labour but I
really have asked myself after the
Russia and scruple scandal where where
people saw Corbin is really weak on that
he said I really don't know whether I
could ever practically vote to put him
into Downing Street and I think what it
shows is people are very pragmatic but
they also want to see I think centigram
politics come back in our country and
and that's something that maybe they
feel her slightly gone and the brexit
debate feeling like it's polarizing
public opinion when actually what people
want to see our politicians working
together for people and it being less
about the politics and bit more about
them later on you're pretty close in
Wandsworth are you worried about your
own seat and the next election oh I just
do my very best my local community and
then it's up to them who they want
representing them at the next election
but I do think I won that seat from
Labour in 2005 and actually the
political climate there wasn't a million
miles away from where it is now people
disenchanted with labour at the time but
not really feeling like the
Conservatives were a necessarily a good
alternative
so I think you win by being in the
centigram but by I think for London
Conservatives we had a very modern open
outlook liberal outlook I think it was
just modern politics about delivery on
the ground for people and taking their
priorities as a local community making
them ours and then backing that up with
a record to live of delivery day-to-day
that people could see for themselves so
that's how they kept it is that why you
think the Conservative Party's at the
moment in the center ground this open
politics that you're talking I don't
think that people necessarily feel that
I think people feel we have gone more
towards the right than perhaps we had
under David Cameron for example there's
that mistake you think I think we I
think you win elections by having a
broad coalition of support for you as a
party I think the last time we won an
election of with any massive majority it
was in 1987 we have got to be a party
that really connects not just with how
people think about a government that
runs Britain in their interest but how
they feel about our country and in terms
of where we go on brexit you know III
think my experience talking to people on
the doorstep is they want to get through
brakes and they want us to get onto
what's the kind of country were trying
to build
after brexit and and really this
perpetual preoccupation with breaks it's
perhaps understandable but I think they
see politicians is really obsessing over
that when what they want is for the
political class to really start focusing
on what's after and what what are we
gonna do about the issues that drove the
brexit vote in the first place for
example the fact that people growing up
in very different parts of the country
seem to have very different chances of
reaching their potential and having
opportunity on that point you went to a
comprehensive school in Rotherham
you were the first person your families
go to university do you think the
Conservatives are doing enough to speak
to those 18 year old aspirational kids
their mother I think we do need to do
more we've got a good message with them
we've always been the party that stands
for equality of opportunity the
challenge we've got as a country is
that's never been the case in practice
and we now need to ask ourselves as a
party and
ask ourselves as a country what is it
going to take to make sure that it
doesn't matter where you're growing up
it doesn't matter what your
circumstances are you can have an equal
shop and we shot at opportunity we can't
have a closed shop when it comes to
opportunity people still feel like it's
connections that matter more than your
talent more than your competence and and
we've got to change that but it needs to
be the Conservative Party that's really
leading the charge on showing how we can
do that practically in modern Britain so
to coin a phrase there's a time to take
back control of the conservative party
from the sentiment people at you I think
I think people want to hear pragmatic
voices in the Conservative Party that
aren't ideologically driven but are
focused on putting people first not the
politics now I want to move on to brexit
because she told my colleague Faisal
Islam earlier this week that certain
probe reps that Conservative MPs
are acting like Russia on the UN
Security Council vetoing everything that
they don't like what did you mean by
that what I mean is that in the end
there's going to be need to be give and
take and the voices that we tend to hear
in brexit are passionate understandably
but they tend to be on the the kind of
wings of the argument either very
passionate that this was a big mistake
and we should be going back into Europe
and getting rid of this result I don't
agree with that all very passionate that
we now got the vote when we absolutely
have to deal on it deliver on it in its
most purest form I don't agree with that
either what we need is something that is
politically sustainable and that
respects the result but actually
recognizes that if we don't deliver a
conservative brexit in other words it
has our values that it has its heart as
in a strong economy well-managed public
finances opportunity then actually it
won't be something I believe that
carries the whole country I represent
one of the youngest constituencies in
the whole country Pfizer is the youngest
constituency demographically alongside
Battersea and unless you make it work
for communities like mine as those
voters get older and they form a bigger
part of the elect
they will simply demand a change soup
and I don't spend in the next 10 to 15
years as a country continuing to debate
and argue about our relationship with
our European neighbors will serve this
country's future well we need to resolve
this debate and argument now we need to
put the divisions it's created behind us
and we need to look ahead and debate
what's the kind of country we want to be
after brexit that is the most important
thing to me you've got to get breaks
that sort of first haven't you I'm keen
to talk specifics and for everyday
debating it that's the challenge you've
got Jake every smoke stares at all he's
doing is trying to get Teresa main to
stick to the promise she already made to
leave the Customs Union and what's your
view on that should the UK leave their
customs union I'm interested in the
outcomes I think we have to respect that
we need the process first don't we we
can't just talk about the outcomes we
need to work out how to get there and
whether or not we're going to be in the
customs union is surely at the heart of
that it is but in the end I think
there's what does the customs union
represent for us it's about being able
to trade freely and when goods and
services are crossing borders have that
happen in a way that's not uric rat ik
and all I guess people like myself is
saying is it's how we actually deliver
on that continuing that matters it
really matters when it comes down to the
Good Friday Agreement and Northern
Ireland we can't go backwards on the
politics there that is absolutely
crucial I think for lots of moderate
conservatives like myself but what we
want now is this discussion resolved the
Prime Minister needs to get the
parliamentary party behind her she has
our backing and I think she now needs to
get the backing of some of the harder
brexit ears and they need to recognize
that that a successful approach on
brexit is gonna need compromise not just
in the country as a whole but also in
the Conservative Party and also from
them and that's what they now need to do
is be prepared to have some
give-and-take and it's gonna gonna have
to crack a few eggs to make an omelet
I'm afraid on the brexit situation and
they need to recognise that and who is
they I mean it's obvious that you're
talking about people like Jake every
small but it's also let's be frank
people around the cabinet table as well
isn't it you're talking about people
like Boris Johnson
who reportedly has said that they're
ready to resign from the cabinet if
Teresa may pushes ahead with staying in
a customs union or customs partnership
well yes I hope they can show some
leadership and I hope they can recognize
that it's going to require give-and-take
and that will require giving take from
them as well and all I can say is is I
resign from government and I've gone to
the back benches and I'm doing just fine
and I'm enjoying the additional freedom
and I can campaign on the things that
matter - so you're saying it wouldn't
actually be too bad if some of these
breaks are Taylor stepped down from
cabinet I'm saying we have to decide
what's important to all of us from my
perspective I left government because I
wanted to campaign on something that
matters to me hugely which is social
mobility I don't accept Britain as it is
today being a country where where you're
growing up means you get very different
chances in life that's just plain wrong
I think it's wrong for individuals I
think it's bad for communities and I
think it's bad for our country overall I
actually think if you if you think of a
Britain where we all did get an equal
shot opportunity where people did get a
chance to make the most of their
potential that's really the key to
success for us in the 21st century in
the 21st century it's all going to be
about a knowledge economy it's gonna be
about countries that can make the most
of their people and that's what I want
to see our country do now let's get to
the important bit of this brexit debate
shall we because yes the brexit ears
have been making that loud noises but
let's be honest they don't actually have
the numbers to really hold the Prime
Minister hostage to what they want you
on them or remain supporting side of the
Conservative Party do so what are your
red lines would you be prepared to rebel
against the government I mean it's not
about red lines we're all gonna have to
realize that we have to find some kind
of a sustainable agreement within the
Conservative Party itself I would
describe myself as a moderate I
absolutely accept that we're leaving the
EU but the question is how do you do
that in a way that brings the broad mass
of the British public with you when we
know the vote was broadly split how do
you do it in a way that protects our
economy that protects our public
finances and that means it doesn't come
breaks it doesn't come at the expense of
social mobility and
and where you want to get to but the
reality is your most powerful tool is
the fact that you can defeat the
government that's the way to get
listened to isn't it if you don't like
the brexit vision that's been put
forward I think the way to get Millicent
I think the way to get listened to is
not to send letters that get published
in the paper and make ultimatums through
the papers that I think it's to get
round the table and to hash out a deal
of what's an alternative that's really
going to bring the overall Conservative
Party with it I don't think people can
afford to stay in their comfort zones
however convenient and easy that may
feel for them I'm willing to compromise
I think we all have to if we're going to
show some leadership I think people are
frankly fed up with a brexit debate that
seems to be focused all about the
personalities all about the politicians
they're not about people and that needs
to change and I think the Prime Minister
came into her role wanting to bring
people together but she can only do that
if people are willing to make
compromises and that's what I think the
parliamentary party and members of the
cabinet now need to be prepared to do
just finally and before we do these
interviews are sometimes asked people in
social media if they have any questions
for our guests and one that came up a
couple of times actually with you is
would you be prepared to run for London
man and if you could give a straight
answer I'm sure the people who put that
questionnaire forward would be very
happy well I I thought I'll get through
the the London elections first before
thinking about anything
next I literally just left her left
cabinet because I've never felt I needed
a role in politics to particularly
define myself or or make what I'm doing
feel worthwhile the the main job I've
always compared to come or always cared
about is being member of parliament at
Putney so now I haven't I haven't made
my mind up at all on any of that stuff
it's not particularly what drives me
what drives me is what I want to try and
achieve for my community in my country